let's get right to hatred mail this week.
Quick reminder.
What is hatred?
Mail
[inaudible].
It's like a mandatory transvaginal ultrasound
for your mind.
Patriot mail written by Patriots.
Who hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom.
Okay.
This hatred male.
I say this like it's unusual.
This hatred mail contain some contradictions.
Let's see if you can spot them as we listen
together.
Pacman is a lying, cunning Jew.
No, mr Pacman, you or anyone alive can be
100% Jew.
Why?
Well before there were Jews around homo sapiens
was already out there.
Since Jews arose from people that were not,
you cannot be 100% if you claim you are, you
must prove that the very first people were
Jewish and that no where along a millions
of years long line that was dilated to even
the smallest extend and that is without even
consider and that we arose from critters that
were not humans down to the very first living
thing.
Lot of confusion here, I'm allying cunning
Jew and also Jews don't really exist according
to this person which is, which is fascinating.
I'm a contradiction as much as antisemitism
staples of a of hatred mail that we receive
remembered.
The best way to fight hatred, autism is to
use the coupon code hatred@fortyandgrabamembershipatjoinpacman.com
when you do that, you were supporting us.
You're getting 40% off with the coupon code,
Patriot 40 and it makes hatreds cry.
It's like a dream where you're just trying
to punch someone and you can't, you can't
land a blow.
That's what it feels like to a hatred when
they write in these screeds.
And then people just sign up with the coupon
code Patriot 40.
So take advantage of it.